as of last week the paragon team pushed
out what's likely to be their final
update on April 26th Epic Games will
abandon its free-to-play MOBA Paragon
has been in early access in open beta
for over two years now it built a player
base of more than five million players
and a development team that pushed out
well over 100 updates and now the game
is effectively canceled after a rocky
start gaming outlets claimed it had made
a comeback but clearly not a lasting one
where did it go wrong
[Music]
Paragon was announced in 2015 as a
mobile for PlayStation 4 and PC epic set
out to make a MOBA that embraced
third-person action elements with an
emphasis on mobility the developer
wanted to showcase the power of its
in-house Unreal 4 engine while pushing
the boundaries of the genre the idea was
to merge the fast-paced action of
third-person shooters with the strategy
and team compositions of a MOBA in 2016
Paragon went into paid early access with
13 heroes and one large map players
could finally experience one of the
best-looking MOBAs to date while the
game eventually transitioned to
free-to-play at the start you could buy
a $20 founders pack a $60 challengers
founder pack or a $100 masters founder
pack all of these versions gave you
access to the game and a slew of digital
content to get you started
Paragon saw some success but not without
its share of issues due to the large map
size players needed to be able to move
quickly so the team introduced a travel
mode speed this allowed players to
toggle between two movement speeds one
to get around the map and the other for
combat it proved helpful getting around
the map however players would use it to
easily flee resulting in frustrating
engagements despite this the dev team
was transparent and constantly looking
for feedback from the community they
continually tweaked and updated the
growing cast of heroes eventually
capping it at 38
[Music]
in August 2017 the game left early
access and entered a free-to-play open
beta however fans could purchase a
physical version of the game called the
essentials Edition for $60 which
included the beta and a bunch of in-game
currency and other digital goodies from
this point forward Paragon went through
a series of changes in an attempt to
streamline matches the map size was
decreased players were more
conventionally funneled into lanes to
increase engagements and the movement
speed was continuously tweaked in order
to find a sweet spot however instead of
really fixing the movement problem epic
introduced a new smaller map called
monolith that replaced the original
welcome to the monolith update bringing
you the new battleground in Paragon
compared to our legacy map monolith is
more compact easier to navigate and
features faster paced action than ever
before the loadout system that allowed
players to equip six modifiable cards
was reduced to three cards that couldn't
be modified this was an attempt to make
it more approachable once these changes
were implemented players took notice and
some express concerns after that the
player count began to drop and this
downward spiral continued due to
balancing issues the diehard fans who
had spent hours fine-tuning loadouts
mixing and matching different cards and
learning all the ins and outs were left
by the wayside but above all fans were
torn on the new map some liked it
because it was quicker paced but others
felt it ruin the strategy to make
matters worse due to movement speed
changes the original map was removed
altogether epic tried to make Paragon
more accessible but in doing so they
alienated the player base that was
propping the game up streamlining
systems to reach a broader audience
isn't inherently a bad thing
monster hunter world has seen a lot of
success thanks to this but Capcom wasn't
constantly rewriting the script while
hundreds of thousands of people were
playing sure sweeping changes and
overhauls it to be expected when it
comes to early access but the changes
fans endured with Paragon seemed like
attempts to chase trends triple-a
publishers and developers are always
looking for the next big thing but at
what point does a game like Paragon or a
developer like epic lose its identity
[Music]
here we are in 2018 and Paragon is
coming to an end there are many factors
that could have spelled the death of
Paragon but the most obvious and most
likely is the recent success of
fortnight a game that oddly enough was
following a similar marketing courses
Paragon the game launched with a paid
early access beta version and will
eventually become free-to-play this year
however fortnight's boom in popularity
wasn't necessarily due to the game that
epic shipped back in july it's thanks to
battle royale a free-to-play version of
fortnight that has recently hit 45
million players and two million
concurrent's an absurd number that blows
Paragon out of the water but once again
is a battle royale mode true to
fortnight is it just another example of
epic chasing trends with Paragons
dwindling numbers and fortnight's
explosion I have to wonder did epic
shift resources work power and time to
its star player only to neglect the game
that so many veterans loved but not
everyone thinks that fortnight's Rises
what led to paragons demise one redditor
the rough stuff has tracked 10-cents
involvement with epic games Tencent is a
massive and I mean massive Chinese
investing company that some 330 million
into epic games which translates to
nearly half its shares but what does
that have to do with Paragon while
Tencent is also the primary shareholder
of riot the developer behind League of
Legends the rough stuff claims that once
Paragon started to pick up steam Tencent
took notice and became more and more
invested with the project so it wouldn't
become a direct competitor with League
of Legends rather than pitting it
directly against League measures were
taken to make Paragon more casual in
order to compete with heroes of the
storm and smite I'm paraphrasing the
rough stuffs long in-depth breakdown of
10-cents involvement but this could have
played a role in Paragons fall well I
don't think Paragon would have come
close to league's popularity and may
have had the potential to pull some of
the players due to its next-gen feel and
fast paced
action personally I think it was a bit
of both Paragon had been revamped so
many times with inconsistent results
while fortnight struck gold with its
battle royale mode almost immediately
there's no telling what epic could have
done with Paragon to even reach a
fraction of fortnight's popularity it's
hard to say how much epic is made off
these two games but 45,000,000 has a
much better ring to it than 5-million
[Music]
so what's left of Paragon even though
these last few months have been
tumultuous Paragon has built up a
community of dedicated fans some
invested hundreds of hours hundreds of
dollars filled the forums with tons of
feedback and created community
tournaments and fan sites although the
fanbase was an enormous it was resilient
it was pulled a ton of different
directions over the course of two years
as epic continually reworked the game
and refocused its direction the good
news is that epic is refunding players
who invested more than time into the
game unfortunately the process is
arduous and time-consuming asking you to
provide receipts dates and item
descriptions but a mere refund doesn't
account for the hours the community
spent beta testing the game in supplying
epic with a constant stream of feedback
over the years it's hard not to feel
burned after all of that Paragon wasn't
just a game that was canceled after a
few trailers or a game can shortly after
an early access period it was a triple a
game that built up a community with a
two-year early access beta test and then
shuddered before it came to fruition
Star Wars Galaxies and halo 2 have
suffered similar fates but both those
games were live for nearly a decade
Paragon has been playable for two years
scrolling through Paragons reddit page
there are hundreds of posts from
disappointed fans some claim they won't
jump over to fortnight or any epic game
for that matter out of principle others
are recounting inside jokes and
highlights over the years and some are
even begging epic to sell the IP to
another company that will continue to
support it
I can't imagine the latter ever
happening as of now it seems like
Paragons fate is sealed
you
you